hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a daa center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more
[Music]
how are you guys
doing right-wing proponent Nigel farage
who was known for a single issue which
was brexit has now started to into
different directions and has for some
reason started to comment on Muslims in
Britain let's take a look at some of the
comments that he's made recently and
come back and respond in kind we have a
growing number of young people in this
country who do not subscribe to British
values in fact loathe much of what we
stand for so what do you do who are we
talking about there oh I think we see
them on the Streets of London every
Saturday what do they look like oh we're
talking about what do they look like are
we talking about Muslims here we are and
and I'm afraid I found some of the
recent surveys saying that 46% of
British Muslims support hammers support
a terrorist organization that is
prescribed in this country so we you and
and and what's interesting is that this
prime minister this prime minister is
building up far more of that population
than anybody before in history now many
things have been said uh by different
people proponents of media and I've been
following some of the comments of you
know some right-wing people who have
actually said quote unquote well tell us
what he said that is wrong I mean he's
saying that Muslims in this country who
let's say constitute about
7% of the countries
population that Muslims in this country
in the United Kingdom they don't respect
fundamental British values and that
something needs to be done about this
and he cited as an example uh the amount
of Muslims who supported uh the
proscribed terrorist organization the UK
Hamas as evidence for this now the first
question is what are fundamental British
values fundamental British values are
five in number they are the rule of law
tolerance democracy individual liberty
and um respect these are the five you
know bog standard if you like British
values that you have in National
curricula all around the country and
that are taught to students in this
country so if we ask the question is it
the case that there is something
inherent about the religion of Islam or
about the Muslim communities or is there
sociological evidence that suggests that
those five aspects are in all respects
rejected by the Muslim Community I would
say that's actually an inaccurate
statement let's take the first thing
democracy for example democracy by the
vast majority of traditionalist Orthodox
Muslim commentators and Scholars is
considered to be acceptable if used
instrumentally of course it's not seen
as an objective truth in and of itself I
mean Plato himself had issues with
democracy and there's philosophers even
in the western tradition that had issues
with democracy as a system as an
objective truth or as a pragmatic usage
so democracy it's not actually correct
to say that well Muslims reject
democracy and all the results of
Representative Democratic processes so I
don't think that's we can put that set
as side for now second thing you can say
is respect there's nothing in the
religion of Islam which indicates that
respect is to be forgot or is not to be
uh upheld in fact and this is a very
subjective term what do we mean by
respect but if you're asking the
question about Islam and Muslim people
in particular there's nothing there to
suggest that number three if you talk
about tolerance well I mean there are
many verses in the Quran which state
quite explicitly and quite candidly that
people can live in whatever or using
whatever system they want to use for for
their life whatever world view they want
to use for
example in chapter 109 of the Quran you
have your religion we have
ours whoever wants to can believe and
whoever wants to can disbelieve where
it's mentioned in chapter 2 verse 256
that that there is no compulsion in
religion this is Islam Islam does in
fact state that you know we're not meant
to convert people forcibly in this way
so if we're asking does
Islam practice tolerance yes you'll say
of course some say you you guys don't
actually have tolerance towards the LGBT
community or this community or that
community in the British context or in
the context of the western world there's
no scholar or reputable scholar across
the world in Islam that says that there
should be or there should be some kind
of intolerance practiced against members
of communities which we disagree with
the practices of for example lgbtq
communities Etc so I don't think there's
enough evidence to suggest that on a
sociological level on a classical
Islamic level that you know uh tolerance
is not upheld in Islam and or by Muslims
um in the in the United Kingdom or
anywhere else in the
west what about individual liberty now
this is connected obviously liberalism
with a small L as an ideology as
something I've spoken about at length is
not something which is compatible with
Islam in the uh broad sense but
individual liberty if we're talking
about people to choose whatever they
want in the western context once again
there's no scholar worth his salt or her
salt that would say that such a thing is
uh we we should rebel against it in the
western context so really and truly here
and ruer law of course rule of law
Scholars are very explicit at the fact
that you should obey the law of the land
so long as it does not contradict
Islamic law uh if you're living so you
could make the argument actually that
fundamental British values from one
angle of from one respect it's not
something we are in opposition to from
that perspective from the pragmatic or
contextual perspective of course if you
go deeper you can say there are points
of tension as an objective reality so
that's one thing then he cites well 46%
of people believe he says 46 you know
Muslims believe uh or support Hamas well
I just looked at a study done by yugov
which is seen as a reputable and
credible organization that says that of
the people that support Palestine in
Britain as a whole 14% of them actually
supported Hamas now that can't be
constitutive of the entire Muslim
population because there only 7% of
Muslims in the UK which shows you that
there are people who support Hamas who
are not Muslims in the United Kingdom
this is um unusual you could you could
argue because it's a prescribed
terrorist organization but suffice it
for me to say it's not a prescribed
terrorist organization in the majority
of the world I mean Hamas is not this is
a fact majority of countries do not
consider them to be a prescribed
territory in fact Switzerland for the
longest of time and Norway for the
longest of time these are European
countries did not consider them to be
terrorist organiz I think they may have
changed that recently but the point is
just because something is seen as a
prescribed terrorist organization it
doesn't mean to say that the people who
support that group are necessarily
against fundamental British values the
like of which we've just mentioned it's
actually
conceivable that someone could could
make a case for Hamas as a
non-prescribed terrorist organization
which many have and still claim at least
to uphold fundamental British values
that's the first thing the second point
which is very important is that the same
tensions which may exist with the
dominant ethic of the
West and Islam could also said to be
existing within Judaism and the dominant
ethic of the West which just say
liberalism Classical liberalism so if
you wanted to make a case about Muslims
because of lack of integration say or
opposition to what you consider to be
fundamental British values and or the
dominant ethic of the west then you
could say the same thing about Orthodox
Jews and this is something that abdalah
Andi recently came on gbb news and you
know done a fantastic job in being able
to expound on in great detail and you
can see his video in the link below and
that is enough of sober analysis for us
to say I'm sorry to say uh farage you
have not been able to make the case in a
strong enough
Manner and to specialize this to make it
a remarkable case of the Muslim
Community and cize and otherize the
Muslim Community above and beyond other
communities like the Jewish Community or
other communities even maybe the S
Community Orthodox seek communities and
other maybe uh even Evangelical
Christian communities within the West I
think speaks volumes about your
disingenuity it speaks volumes about how
you perceive Muslims in this country and
it may even speak volumes about maybe
who could be and this may be a question
I should ask you is paying who's paying
you uh to speak like this because back
in the days you and Robinson and others
used to all have this very patriotic Pro
Britain approach and it seems to me the
parli is changing isn't it Nel now it
seems to me that you're more concerned
with Israel and for foreign politics
than you are with national politics of
Great Britain that's what I will
say your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center this Center this Masid this
educ ational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even more